so let's do this let me uh we'll give
you the big update here
uh this is the news story i want i want
you to see this this is the ap's
official report
that's it it's one sentence repeated
twice
from the ap judge bans proud boys leader
from nation's capital
after arrest on vandalism and weapons
charges and then it says that that's the
title
and then it says washington ap judge
bans proud boys leader from nation's
capital after arrest and vandalism
weapons charges
that's the whole story some pretty deep
reporting ap
yeah but so the other thing he got
arrested uh enrique so he arrives in dc
we talked about yesterday
he had two high-capacity magazines on
him not even weapons
dc's laws are so strict you can't even
have that you can't you can't have ammo
so we got a mesmeter charge for that but
i think
you know with with a lot of some of
these supporters saying that they want
to you know come bringing weapons
we'll see if people actually show up i
don't know if there was that many people
there today but tomorrow
is supposed to be the big day today was
just like a preliminary event
but i think it'll get uh particularly
interesting
but i wonder if you know there's going
to be i guess the political
willpower among trump supporters to
actually go and do anything that might
change
really anything i suppose well i don't
think they can i think it's just more
more of a you know a rah-rah we're
showing our spirit and support kind of
thing because they
protest i i look i i i get that it's
part of a
you know just trying to keep morale up
you know but
i generally dislike protests me too
on any side i think they're i think for
the most part they're useless and
and and you know you want to you want to
go down to dc tomorrow
be my guest i'm not saying don't do it
uh you'll be around a bunch of people
that
that you know you're are like-minded and
it'll be great and you'll have a fun
time
is it going to do anything no absolutely
not
this is why louis gomer said the message
basically from the supreme court was
that conservatives need to be as violent
as anti-fun black lives matter
see that's
i see what i i get what he's saying i
don't agree with it but i
i but the fact is that that antifa
and all these groups are not being
maligned by the media
right so so then you can say well hey
we're we're doing the same thing as
antifa they're not catching any flack
you're only going after us because we're
conservatives
and that's i mean that's what's going to
happen how many antifa people have been
you know snatched up as soon as they
entered and barred from dc that's the
crazy thing about this
does a judge have a right to kick you
out of a city that's that's kind of nuts
do you think that this is something that
will you know
uh there'll be some kind of lawsuit
down the line do you think that that's
something that could happen you know i
gotta be honest go fund me and just kind
of
the really hardcore trump supporters get
mad when i say stuff like this because
it's
true and i guess they don't want to hear
it and it's that
conservative like look you you voted for
trump
andrew pass no no i did of course but
you're not going to go protest you don't
like to protest right and i'm not saying
this is disparagingly it's just
i think most of the people who recognize
what's going on
don't want to go out screaming smashing
burning destroying right
and trump supporters don't do that
exactly they don't and so
antifa does and antifa wins and then the
police protect them not always
but often even even when they do get
arrested the district
district attorneys cut them loose
conservatives won't
they don't go out they don't get active
they're not loud and thus they're not
paid attention to
and it's another reason why a lot of
people in media are scared of them
and will will not cover this stuff
because they know they'll get attacked
but also if look at what happened to
kyle
in house yeah they'll they'll know when
when they are defending when they when
they go and defend when they try to make
a difference
when they try to push back
then they get totally screwed and then
then so oh my god whatever 10 million
people showed up in dc
and said enough you'd make a change
where are they going to burn down the
trauma they're saying if they actually
showed up in mass which they don't do
that either
well it depends it depends on how much
institutional support you have because
you know when we see protests sometimes
they do make a difference sometimes they
don't when it came to the iraq war we
saw some of the biggest protests in the
united states
and it absolutely didn't do anything and
now another thing to really consider
here is a lot of leftists and a lot of
left kind of thinking leaders are always
making the argument that you need to
ride
you need to burn down businesses you
need to be violent because when you do
you are heard and there are examples
that they specifically point to saying
that there was injustices we protested
we peacefully marched nothing happened
this is what the left says that's not
what i'm saying right but they're saying
but when we did riot we finally did get
the national
media attention we finally did get
everyone watching us we finally did get
changed because we
put our words to action and actually
made something that made people look at
us and watch and actually do something
that's the argument that the lefts are
making that that should be somewhat kind
of considered here than talked about
honestly
instead of i'm sorry tim instead of a
protest you can have a movement like the
tea party movement which is something
that made a difference it was that was
a that that was a thing that that
actually
changed we you know we took back we took
back
the senate essentially we took back we
did any real life change though
well because like but we're not burning
down buildings
yeah well no no i'm not advocating i'm
not advocating not everything has to be
the french revolution no i'm not
advocating for it but we're but
we we need to kind of lay out their kind
of philosophy and their actions to
understand it
and and it's i think there's some you
know fair points that they bring up
i kind of think this is like the new
form of protest on the internet
like tim making a video you protest in
your videos you're free you're like
angry about something and you're
protesting that thing this is ridiculous
look at this
and people are listening people listen
to this
i think we stopped a war in syria in
2012 because of our internet protest
so that's why i don't go to these giant
crowds where you get smushed in like a
sardine and if they fire mustard gas
you're gonna choke to death or whatever
you're you're right but it's not twenty
twenty twelve
did you say 2016 2012 2016 is when it
happened you know why
donald trump got elected and that's what
stopped
the escalators i remember 2011 when they
were talking about um
we put boots on there around 2012 2013
when
when the so they said they said that he
had gassed his own people
and obama was going to take us in there
was something i remember we are changing
involved with that i might listen i
might be wrong about that but i think
you guys are going to know
about it you're right but your ears are
off obama did bring us in
then people on the internet started
posting memes complaining propping up
trump and pushing for trump trump wins
and then trump immediately says i don't
want to do this what i'm thinking of is
before trump it was an obama and obama
decided we're not going in
obama put soldiers in syria period but
it happened
yeah but no one said it wasn't a full
invasion like iraq and uh
well they were planning to libya uh to
do the same thing that they did in libya
in syria
and there was a a lot of extensive
pushback but also
there was a lot of protest i mean i i
you know i was a part of like
filming a lot of people and their voices
and it was
in a time and period where the internet
wasn't fully censored yet so those
voices were extremely popular
but we also have to remember it was also
russian warships
that literally went in front of american
warships
right next to syria and said you do this
we are going to have a bigger conflict
and a bigger fight here
now the topic of protest it's a very
interesting one you could point
to examples where it didn't do jack
squat you could point to examples where
it did do something
like in poland with the sally sardar
movement
where people you know peacefully
protested they petitioned and they also
just had a workers strike and that
helped make a big difference well that's
right that was the solid
i mean solidarity right yes and that
brought people together against the
communist government that was ruling
their lives and being
very unjust so it so there are instances
where it works and it doesn't work
uh so so we need to understand we can't
just see it as black and white
but you're talking about you're talking
about uh i'm talking about protest right
protest
but then we talk about you know then you
mix in worker strikes and then
you know it's it's a big part of a
farmer's strike let me let me ask you a
question though yes
if a million trump supporters showed up
in dc tomorrow
and blocked all the roads how could a
joint session of congress even happen
to count any votes
maybe they're all in dc already i don't
know i mean
i i maybe it can't i don't know i'm just
imagining you know i think what did alex
jones say 10 million people or something
like ridiculous number did they say
i don't remember exactly but they're the
legal amount that they're allowed to
have is thirty thousand
yeah well they see that for the protest
tomorrow well forget about the legal
amount yeah
right then that's when you wanna go well
you know what are you gonna do exactly
you know but what is in
the national guard they can't do that
what if so many people show up that
they're just the roads are blocked like
even not even intentionally
and it obstructs the process by which dc
is supposed to function
it's you know geez they'll have to
remote it well then what a novel concept
then that's you say what i thought the
phone in the office
yeah they'll have to do it by remote in
the 21st century
but how do you verify the person who's
voting is the real person you gotta you
gotta stream it live on
the chat no there's filters people use
all the time to mask and and do they
would do it through webex and live
they would vote through web apps yeah it
would be so you know they're not an
android in
in congress right now no but but we we
do have people
live filters and stuff like that so we
they they come in and they vote in
person there's
but they are doing a lot of remote
voting anyway
it i think it's a film i think it's the
fact that there's a certain number of
people that can shut down
you know any city that's true they're
just peacefully protested but
you know a protest is you're talking
more about a shutdown that's
no no i'm saying well here's a question
if a million people
were walking around in dc like you babe
shoulder to shoulder on the streets
in many circumstances not even
intentionally blocking anything they'd
be
in the way making things impossible to
do i mean it's a wednesday
do you think 10 people are you know
there's going to be a million people no
no no i'm not saying there will be
or that there could be i'm saying that a
protest could have that power
a protester of that size would have a
such a massive impact but would really
obstruct things but it wouldn't
obstruct yes but would it change
something it sounds like you're saying
noah get the boat
if if we can't deal with corruption and
bloat
and i i love aoc just being this
progressive who supports nancy pelosi in
basically everything
it's amazing at least like when you look
at the republicans
you're republicans for and against trump
and it's kind of split
12 senators supporting him and a bunch
not look at the progressives they're
like well you know
we will vote for nancy pelosi even
though we hate our guts right
why well but we don't want kevin
mccarthy to be
you know the speaker if you if they know
you're going to bend and just give them
whatever they want they'll never give
you what you want i'd be willing to bet
kevin mccarthy could cut a deal with the
progressives they'd probably say better
than nothing
can can i ask you just to slightly
derail
you you were on the ground for for
occupy wall street
yes huge would you say that was a
protest or a movement
uh it was a movement okay yeah you could
do anything
ultimately did it do anything it got the
dnc to transfer all their funds
from i think it was bank of america to
amalgamated which was a union-controlled
bank
yeah which was a big victory for them
there's a lot of people moving
their money from big banks to local
small banks and
credit unions yeah sure credit union saw
a major boost so it was really damaging
to big banks it really was
uh when you go down and talk to all the
random people other different ideas
oh it was it was a lot it was lovable
chaos yes how they had no idea at the
time what they were really
fighting for but they did create certain
amounts of amounts of pressure i
remember
you we were we were there at that bernie
sanders book signing right luke was it
you were there
in dc i believe so yes and then we were
waiting in line for like i think it was
like
meat or something like in a buffet and
the guy i'm pretty sure it was you and
me and the guy was saying next to us
saying that he worked for
credit unions and that because of occupy
wall street they saw something like 500
billion dollars transfer from banks into
credit unions
credit unions are non-profit banks that
reinvest in their community so
when uh if you have uh when i worked for
american eagle airlines we had the aaa
credit union so that meant
that money that profit went towards
loans for
you know employees you know our union
members to buy stuff
there's also uh but i'm i'm a member of
the uh
uh navy federal credit union is i should
probably shouldn't say what bank i'm
using but
it's armed service personnel and so the
money that would normally be
profit for shareholders is reinvested
giving the members
amazing benefits like with with navy
federal you can travel internationally
and it's like no international fees or
exchange rates it's awesome
and that's because armed service
personnel frequently get deployed to
various places
so that was big that was great that was
i think i think
i i often advocated for many as
occupiers to see that as one of the
biggest and most important victories
possible
taking away economic power from big
corporate banks and bring them to
non-profit community centered credit
unions
because i would always complain these
antifa types would go and smash windows
and stuff like that right
and i would say what do you think
happens when that 30 000 a year banker
shows up for his job in the morning and
there's glass all over his desk and his
computer he's going to be
like why what did i do i don't
understand why did you attack me
when you show up and you spray paint or
bolt the doors shut or whatever
i'll tell you what the most effective
protest would it would be don't smash
the window of the bank
put on a nice pair of slacks nice
button-up shirt stand out in front with
some pamphlets
smile and shake hands and give pamphlets
for credit unions that reinvest
in low-income communities and then guess
what how much damage can you really do
to a bank when you break a window
1000 bucks maybe but you'll make all of
the working-class people there hate you
how much damage could you do if you
convince just five people in one week
to move their average savings to credit
union that could be a hundred thousand
those banks are flimsy man
a few if they lose a small percentage of
their funds that they go under yeah
people need to understand voting with
your dollar voting your what your
actions is absolutely insurmountable it
is so
critically important and i think maybe
we could even just mobilize or even
we should talk about this privately put
out some call to actions to actually
help support
local small businesses rather than of
course the big mega corporate giants
that are out there
and another thing that i wanted to bring
up because i know you you want something
to say to
say they're pointing at each other dave
portnoy
yes he started busting it himself but
before we get into
dave and what he's doing uh one of the
best protests that i've seen and heard
about and i've i've seen the memes about
were of course the protests
in japan where bus drivers who were
angry
at of course their company for not
giving them the you know proper
wages they decided to protest by of
course
continuing their job not striking but
they didn't charge people
yeah to enter the bus and of course the
but the bus company owners had to of
course capitulate to their needs because
they had all these people using their
services they didn't know how much
normal life they didn't piss anyone off
they just really made sure that they
they did something that actually had a
huge ramification that was still
something that everyone was happy about
yeah so but you brought up a good point
about
fighting for small businesses is one of
like one of the best protest things you
can do right now
uh dave portnoy of bar stool sports
started that fund
where i think how much do they raise
like millions of dollars
12 million 16 yeah last week to help
people whose businesses are hurting
because of the lockdowns
that's not now first i'll say that's
direct relief it's one of the coolest
things i've ever heard in a long time
the next step is how do we stop the
politicians who are
taking a dump on the constitution and
destroying people's businesses
so you know what the answer is really
simple
protest
what will that do yeah if people if
people just uh went about their business
like there was no
lockdown rule define oh well that's a
good performance non-violent civil
disobedience
showing up and opening your doors and if
everybody did it there'd be no lockdown
and the cops can't do anything about it
they can sanctify the order just if if
everybody
instead of going around and marching
just opened the doors to their business
businesses and says we're open
then there's no lockdown it's over i
think all of these businesses
um i mean you you could uh
protest you could protest by uh
prorating your property taxes saying
well look you had me shut down for
this amount of time i'm not gonna pay
the taxes
for for that amount of time because and
then i couldn't make any
tax man show up to your door with some
guns and say i don't care
yeah i go through these things
government wants it's cut maybe i want
any health people
to do certain things like to not pay tax
but i feel like
that just is that is like a form of
incitement like
like to tell people disobey the civil
authority if the civil authority is is
bad or evil well you could
well what you could do you could then
they would maybe take you to court and
then you could go well then i'm counter
suing and i'm
you know and this is the reason why and
maybe there could be
i mean it sounds like there's some
justification to that
right that's what the american
revolution was based on
so yes that's their justice i think i'm
wearing the appropriate shirt for this
you are
say the least but um again many things
we could do many different small actions
but again it all comes down to
people being aware of what's going on so
they actually know what actions to take
and i definitely think we need to
mobilize and organize a lot more than
just the kind of pontificating and
thinking that we do here and i think
that might be a next step that i think
we should really kind of consider
you know the biggest problem i think we
have as freedom loving individuals
i swear it's these like whiny
uh fence-sitting podcaster types that
will talk
all day and night about all the problems
won't actually organize them in their
house
sit in their house turn the camera on
complain about something and then do
literally nothing about it
i can just imagine some some of these
people sitting there with like they're
their open button ups and their beanies
complaining all day for a year and then
literally not even doing anything what i
like about internet video is you're
turning words into action
it is something you're creating
something you're not just talk i mean
and speaking is a form of action but
when you record it and turn it into a
commodity
you're creating something with your
words but you're
you're also you're also being an
influencer and that's
and that's a very important thing you
know to to
help i was i wasn't half there but i
think there's an important point in
there's a lot of people like us who will
be like man all these things are bad
oh don't look at me i'm not going to run
for office and do anything about it i'm
just upset
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you